(classical music)
- [Narrator] One of the newest additions
to the skyline in Hamburg, Germany
is a concert hall fit for a modern Mozart.
(classical music)
The Elbphilharmonie is
considered one of the largest
and most acoustically advanced
concert venues in the world.
Made up of three concert halls,
the Elbphilharmonie seats
more than 2,800 visitors.
The Great Concert Hall, the
largest of the three halls,
has 10,000 unique acoustic
panels that were designed
using computer algorithms to
create the best possible sound.
Each panel contains one million cells
that shape the sound by
either absorbing the waves
or having them reverberate
through the space.
The curved design of the cells can be seen
replicated throughout the entire building.
Not to be outdone, the glass exterior
of The Elbphilharmonie built
atop a former warehouse
is just as spectacular as the interior.
The structure rises above the Elbe River
and mirrors the water's wave and shine.
To mark the opening night,
the exterior featured a light show
timed to the music being
played within The Great Hall.
With multiple events almost every day,
The Elbphilharmonie is
a must see for music
and math lovers a like.